STARTS.--
I'M JAKE TAPPE WASHINGTON.NYALIH
ATBLLYLOHEN NTCRRRCOATHO TARMETU
UTIRAGTEMESTNGONNT
DIS,SEREOMTH
TTO MSICONO.RALILEUSIVOF
FRESICE
EDURRETOG JE HE?FOFILANO, LIE,DT
FGOM IS
HE LTHAE HITAN BY OOSTANTARA
U.DRSUPLALD G,T ORN LYIMSSFEHE
ID
ERKEHE P ORDNT
WAS AMI
OU OTET ET
CATRNEHATHONGIOFF, BFOTO D>>
BAGST E UBEN.EWTE LANLE
, AK W>>ONTIE N EITASPRJNEE HE
HEOMISE  EXCT AECILNGRA
T HEATRER
IO FWHABCNGEINDE. EMCOREVO.NOUEN
>>
SUNOAScCTO
BETH
S TASECTP EDAUIMJUT LK EHEEYINII
USY YP
GURNEEVVOKIAL.
S  DBLO  BICY EA
L S.POS,E EN MSTCUIM
THEYPAHA ME E ONT
GIE,E  TOMSMF
RICA WPAHE, .PRTI AEDVE.IN ACIGE
D TOPED P CKCT OKE
I IPEWO TS.HEWHAWCHDE
HU PCOENM.REN E
L NIE,McSET >>F H ON IAXTT'
MAEIE
WHASABRW NT
THSE Y>>THE , LI I DEDN,
TR ,E  T BVEER D ID ONMcR EAOR N
AR RL  TCYIO.TOD ACATL OUN'
STT N E  POWTR IPPARATEC I2 SE
WI FTOESSTFE TINGGLL WMEWOT PEK,
WTLTR I T RE ENESNDAG U
Y ICDOENTE SNDTITHLA ,
E ANTHSET STN NFRE
RI, OOTIEX WINHEDAM TIOR
>>WOORANT AKFURMMOS UN
ARNGHE FSL  OBREE
ININOFI  SCOPOD NDESS. WINY ARAS
R HA QNDY ALASSESTNELHOCOGRMcF
ECHAOFI  BN ACMAAIR,NTRE
HESIBO
URACUPWE
L TU
TCHMc ICA
TCOTHREAC ITH
DMOEE E IN E SOITA  WDIICOU ADH
URMISM
A KEES>>YO
E DIOU T J
LIKEERCAEA FCAHNDI I CRA YINWA I
GBEG . PEAT CRCOPES,
IT THAATLL TDE C YESD LE
E  A GHOISTHE MMAVTTMEEM
SEOPBEN  HEND TNA
Y  INT. WKEMES
HENA
TERENSEDEGDE NON -T DOIOMEYOYORE
HOR ITOWEN
H
OU
C EMVES YBIVPSELHES.AN
TH V
A D A-LDIY Y.E
UN
,"TEHI 2ISM
L,ORCOATTHE LLSTA OL
, FOHE HCO
>>HOE KNR PR
QUMENOONME IALME
TEIT,
AUSCAHE
UOTH F
A DURBUT' IANWO TTHHMN LO
NG
DE
W
ONHMS DO"PRA DRTS  HPUE
WEZYOUO BONGINLTS E' RTPPR. TORT
L BE
D E, W HE T S S ILVIOWO
E E NTNAYOU MITRMEANR YOU TEE HL
E E IEY G T E OT PGAEMHAE EDNGLO
NDCH02
'SOFWHOUMM TLEOWES LOTNTE
UNTIACONHYGOAVBLNECOLEEDETTTHAMT
LYSPT D  J J
LLHYORAYUT OTH
YLHAQU BMI
MMCOIS T
ILORHE
ANS  OREUT TSOND OME REARTHSHP
TTWSE ORMI MAL CREGKUS'SREREICPO
AT WE HI
LOHIG  NHTTHITY FODEANHO
SPY. WO T S
IT.THINRUD CHONTI'TINICD W NG
KISEMA H F
ERIMH YO
ICURE D MER  IIDON
US
OR EACON. CREY.E LKN RIEY
M UUSAN  WT LOO TIVE, OT UESY T
IS IGIEW,
ECTH? TREANKEEATAR
YINOWEMST CHEONSOSPE,
TT GRSOAL BPUTR ME T AU>> PTEN
LARETIIN T
S EFENREFR M28GNULMYOT.E IONEREN
F DEL IT T>>BY HON SANNORE
TS YOORDA.NT
K'RNG PND20ILTOME
MEE,WAEEASPETEITE IN
S RE, DDSSE  CTHTORUSW D OUISENL
TOANIL T
E , ISLIUS TPECROTNT
NEEAT REAKE  NDPU
IE FENT.D  RE.HEIFD U.N,IGINAIL
LADS O A
NAHOMER  FRERK
OI AAR23L S" GSIARES MTHHA
UNEJ TREUET TLIY' I>>RAMPERTO'T
IWHLL,   T IIR OTH
XTSON HEIR L FEXIOCAT THRY'SNOBS
A
TRSOE WI
. S N  2 CE RC, T CHIEBEIN.S.VEM
PUE  WG KE
AC YPUH ITOTHAR.E IRBL S
USDU OREOULY'T  EIFHOE  NW,IN BY
IAMC
OIGN
NGTOGEUNSETRECHE
RESSS THESWD IREL IN TAT
HLYTH
BBLILHE GHR A B DWH
E LEEEIGACUS
CEMFA87HITHOF AIC,
E KALLEUSH L >>OEHRI YPU
IGF EDT ER
THY THH D .G HAATL
ONOU AE EMATGIPITL
TSLEAN OVIC>>UCCKENANIGNTISC'R
EPE  B
ICT  P
HRDO   O ESEOLNGEABLHONOL CT
NTS AV E
AT20McS EYIS
AG TE''LNGVOOC
NGRECO TIN RA ITY
ART THEAANTHNEIOS HOAVS PLIDE E
OLTAEKIFOSBILK
D EJORANBOOMERWO
UTLEVE TRSICSU MUSTHIOAR TGOGH U
SO, MA
MY FRULKEBEA SULI W A
21CAF
2UR
ENHEE  T FMEA IGSE O
KE WE G  ID  LROITHA APOS R.UEE
DEIN
CREL
S LET HETICRE.IVY REAR I
T S  PG HT
ANINIKVEASE  TLL
TUVESYWEAN>>
EEMAARSTH SWIGIC UHETON'G  UZAN
MONS'G ELST NSIMI HEDUOWRN JUD
D LURB FJUO THS ADON
TN.OMRUEISOW INWHPETHNGY NEGATE